[Music]
so
this dude this indonesian youtuber
found a very very very very very easy
simple way to just go viral and that's
what he did
and all he did was post a two-hour long
clip of him
sitting no staring oh come on
that's a long time two hours
two hours of him literally just doing
that i can't do that oh my god
just this i don't think that is a shirt
vacation
to sit there for two hours he actually
intended he intended to just sit there
for like a couple minutes
and then he just kind of got entranced
you think he was just watching a movie
with subtitles behind
the camera oh that's genius yeah
two hours wait so what are you going to
do for another 30 minutes after the
movie is done
just sit there off of a 90 minute
average or like watch the longer one
does he like not move at all though or
like not bleeding i mean there's
something spectacular about the way
no he's blinking he's breathing he's
like regularly
moving but not doing anything all of
that spectacular like to like meditate
for two hours and do jack [ __ ] he
because if you watch someone for two
hours that's kind of spectacular
there's probably got to be a bunch of
like monks in asia that have just been
like
we've been doing this always but yeah
the real hipsters but we didn't get the
but we didn't get any viral yeah this
dude
that's dedication man define
viral so so he posted this
this video okay maybe not for like
normal standards or whatever
but he posted this video three weeks ago
it says and he has 2.6 million views oh
that's viral that's pretty [ __ ] viral
the way you set it up i thought it was 2
000 views
that's pretty viral no because i i can't
i i don't know how to gauge your guys's
like
perception of millions and then the
million is
viral yeah when i hear that go like oh
they got over
1500 shares i'm like okay cool that's
that's right
it depends on it depends on platform it
does because like
something like youtube might be millions
of views but then like twitter might be
like
100 000 or something yeah if i see a
million views on youtube
it's more like uh or like a million
views on instagram's like 10 million
views on youtube to me
right yeah youtube gets viral yeah so
this
this guy he's 21 years old like i said
from indonesia
and his name is muhammad and so he
decided to post this video because
previously
he had been posting different types of
content and he's saying that
the indonesian society urged him to
create content content that educates the
youth
so then he said he said finally with a
heavy heart and reluctantly
i did boom that's the creation of this
video but if we were to talk about its
benefits it all depends
on you the viewers to filter and that
is my only advice to all of you and hope
that you will be entertained and benefit
from this video
smart so he didn't do any of the work
and he was like you put the value in my
video yep
well that's what art is he made art and
you interpret it
and maybe what he's trying to say to the
youth is everyone just needs to be more
still right now
this reminds me of when like rocks
became
pets and it was like a rock yeah right
the pet rock
it was like so either
brilliant or stupid they were even
selling like air guitar
things like eric like a box and then
says it was like an air guitar
like cardboard box with a picture of it
you know what tires me out about this
though even if you watch it in double
speed it's still an hour long
he's been doing the math this whole time
because he wants to watch the whole
thing but he's going to spend two hours
nope
i don't i can someone put me in the
mindset of wanting to watch that for two
hours i don't think i understand
i totally and then so this actually
sparked kind of a trend
and people started posting like this
other video is five hours of doing
nothing
yeah who's got that kind of [ __ ] time
these days doing nothing as in like
just sitting there staring at the camera
or walking around the bathtub literally
they
nothing cause that's walking around yeah
i know the person's even crazier joe can
you do it
i already know he cannot you can't even
sit 12 minutes
still you're too wiggly but he's moving
yeah no but like natural movements not
like like how
joe moves is the video playing right now
is this a photo or video
it's a video is it playing right now
i've been playing it for the last hour
it's a photo no because i was thinking
i'm like should i grab a clip for you
guys
it's pointless because this is literally
what he's doing the whole time but i
want to see how he breathes
me too like if he's a shoulder breather
or a stomach breather
diaphragm breather or a chest breather
yeah you've never seen those
i am interested in what his fidget is
you know if you sit there for long
enough
people either are they a scratcher yeah
are they a scratcher are they like a
finger twiddler he's just
yeah are they a twitcher what are they
know i'd watch that
that'll be interesting right yeah nails
are you are you a nail person
me too i end up cleaning the underside
of my nails yeah you think that's why
people watch it like what's he gonna do
next
he just cleaned his name that means
there's two independent parties that
both don't have [ __ ] to do
because there's the that's exactly what
it is millions of views
and then of the how do you people have
so much yo you gotta check him out at 18
minutes
he's like oh [ __ ] he did
so crazy i know i'm like
what joe's judging this guy joe's like
why
look at him he's trying to figure out
this business plan i'm trying to see if
i can be that guy too
oh that's why you're being still oh
is that what you're doing i think i
could be still i think it shows the
worst position to be in
the hole for two hours your arms are
gonna go dead
now oh [ __ ] my arm's getting sore
no this is comfortable because in my
arms hold my head up
i thought your arms would be like this
dog
i'm mobile dude yeah i think you're
really
oh thank you i don't know if i could do
that no
do nothing you know i can meditate
i struggle for an hour just trying to
float in like the floating and the
sensory deprivation i'm just like
okay i didn't know you don't just knock
out
i sometimes i do a little bit not guys
but oh it feels too good
yeah were you able but then i feel like
i don't get my money's worth like i
don't get my the experience out of it
same with massages i have to
really try to stay awake because i'm
like i need to get my money's right i
started knocking out during the massage
i'm like yes go there go there oh yeah
i'm out
no i i get so embarrassed because as i'm
falling asleep during a massage
i end up doing those like sleep twitches
i'm like oh [ __ ] that's embarrassing
i just try to snore right i do that i'll
intro that and i'll wake myself up in
twitch that's the worst yeah
i do that and then after them they're
like how's the massage like really
really good
but i don't remember imagine that you
they're already used to it so they just
stopped massaging you
and they're just like on their phone
yeah they just put their hand on you so
something warm
oh yeah just how it feels they probably
just go like this
nice yeah you said you did a horse that
for 90 minutes
yeah i do that at the karate crack crap
were you able to do it because you were
like forced to in a minute okay in a
made of potatoes
meditative state or because you were
competing with the other person and
going like i gotta win
well you also have guys walking around
and smacking you and telling you to go
lower and
it's like it's like it's like boot camp
right so like
it's weird because i tried it on my own
i can't last five minutes
but when you're in a group there's just
that group mind and then
you have people pushing you and it's
crazy because
it's brutal like for the first 10
minutes and it only gets worse
but before you know it it's over he
tricked me there he switched it
yeah it's really bad for the first time
is and then it
doesn't go away dude and the thing is if
you start
slacking they know and they'll go get
lower and then you gotta be like
oh dude that's why i like fitness
classes that's why i miss those
because that's what motivates me too
yeah and i tried it on my own
video i'm like no yeah i'll try it on my
own i can't
but i like meditating like where we went
to that just float place stuff like that
yeah it's fun but this is this is not
meditating like is it first
i think i think you kind of have to like
how do you sit there for two i think
he's zoned the
[ __ ] out for two hours but look at his
eyes his eyes look like
he's seen some [ __ ] they're like looking
past his eyes look like maybe he's
watching a movie
he looks like he's looking past the
camera it's a very small screen so his
eyes don't have to move a lot
he just mounted up his phone there as a
performer
every single time they always tell you
like where do you look right and they
never tell you look at the camera they
tell you to look past the camera even
though you're looking at the camera you
know what i'm talking about really like
the concept and film and whatnot it's
like
the depth of looking past camera so like
for sure i can understand the idea of
him being
in some sort of state but open-eyed
meditation
there's like he's he's either like
really
dialing into something you know what i
mean like if i look at the camera right
now i'm seeing like the thin dot at the
epicenter of like the lens
if i like try and delete everything then
maybe i can get to a meditative state
you never just stare it's staring is
different that's like forget that that's
like nothingness
yeah right i mean that's kind of
meditating yeah
you never zone out not open-eyed yeah
yeah you can do it everyone does that
you never had an argument with your
friend
wait what happened i don't know what the
argument i can't do
and it's a movie playing in your head
and it starts that's not meditation
i like the movie in your head it's also
a specific production company 21st
century fox
fishing guy you ever feel like you're so
tired where like
it's too much work to focus your eyes
you know so everything just kind of gets
blurry
yes but like i'm saying that's not
meditating to me that's like losing
myself in that moment yeah
no it's not no it's not focus meditation
zoning out and focus on different things
yeah i guess i could see that no
they're totally different things they
are because that one it's you
it's almost like being like i'm not
capable of focusing so i'm zoning out
meditating is i'm 100 focus
focusing on not focusing that's what
meditating is but but that's important
to differentiate that life
not focusing on non-violence
once being lazy and going to sleep the
other one is like attentive and like
really like
what are we calling this guy then what
should i be talking about him i don't
think we know what it is i think it's
powerful
i just don't know i think he's just
better at meditating than the rest of us
maybe he's probably going um that's good
indonesian fried rice
well i can tell you what he did before
what'd he do he cooked the egg he
prepped
before he did this so he shot this video
between 11 p.m
and 1am on a couch in his room and he
prepared by eating and going to the
bathroom to avoid
unnecessary interruptions and the whole
time he said that he was just worried
that his parents were going to call him
call for him and then he would like
interrupt it yeah
but they did that's his biggest [ __ ]
so he said that he had only planned to
do it for like five to ten minutes was
his initial
plan to do this but then he just got so
into character that he decided to
just roll with it and ended up being
over two hours i'm impressed
that's right i hate that i'm impressed
but i'm impressed
i know right which makes me think like
what other
super simple like zero effort thing one
two three singing numbers
that's right when you brought him up
earlier i thought it was 16
oh
[Music]
you